michael let me ask you did the uh from
that from that moment of the video and
your text exchange that you're saying
uh uh uh you'd be willing to share it
did you guys have a phone call together
or there's not been a phone call or
zoomed together it's just fantastic
as soon as he sent me the text i said
sammy i didn't mean to offend you i'll
take it down i looked at it again
i talked to kurt we had our team take it
off because it was nothing he got his
feelings hurt for all he had to do was
say to me why did you do that oh this is
sammy you know what if it hurt you i'm
sorry i would have taken it out which i
did immediately
immediately with all this prayer
bullying innuendo i don't know what the
heck he's talking about it's all figment
of his imagination
i took it down it was you know what i'll
tell you the truth i'll tell you honest
i am my wife said you know what michael
i can understand how sammy got offended
i said okay i didn't get it you know
what and i'm sorry i'm not making
excuses we just had a kid die in my
house maybe i wasn't thinking right i
don't know
but it certainly wasn't to offend him in
any way and i don't have to soften him
him up i don't know what he's talking
about send him something and what
happened at church patrick you will
understand this yeah i don't have to
pray for somebody maybe it's what your
wife told you
it's maybe what your wife told you
michael what you [ __ ] just did
is not right no your wife told you jimmy
don't inject again many other people
gotta tell excuse me
it was wrong don't inject it again sammy
my wife told me days afterwards when i
mentioned it to her okay i said sammy
got upset
whatever you said it your wife told you
it was wrong it was not a good thing
so
stop the [ __ ] let me let me tell you
something
no
stop your baloney sammy i was man enough
to apologize to you and said it wasn't
meant intentionally to
to betray you your usual words or
anything else and i immediately took it
down so you could you could say whatever
you want as soon as i knew that i took
it down i said i apologize i didn't mean
it
i don't have to soften you up if it was
a mistake it was a mistake but there was
nothing said about you i didn't compare
you i went into great detail about the
witnesses that testified against my
father look at the video again
and i don't even know who those guys
were and i don't
care about those guys the innuendo is
that everybody should not get a [ __ ]
break because they cooperate they should
rise
[ __ ]
by the government well now you [ __ ]
crusader who wants to put everybody in
prison and then you say
they come out and they recommit
i'm talking about your vehicle what are
you doing what am i saying sammy can i
can i uh can i make one recommendation
apologize a hundred more times
[Music]
yeah let me make one recommendation sami
sami if we can if we can have you
uh uh mario's calling your phone if you
get the phone because it's choppy with
your service michael's service is good
yours is a little choppy if you have the
phone next to you i'm going to put it
here you will hear what michael has to
say and we will hear what you have to
say i don't have the phone patrick i do
not have the phone next to me i got it
on uh
airplane or whatever the [ __ ] it is to
shut it up and i'm not interested in
hearing what he has to say and i'm not
even interested in going on and making
this question
to get tired of this [ __ ] thing so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you